we begin this morning with new
information on president Trump's search
to fill the pending vacancy on the
Supreme Court following Justice Anthony
Kennedy retirement announcement this
week the president says he will announce
his a nominee a week from this Monday he
told reporters aboard Air Force One that
he will be interviewing several
candidates over the coming days mr.
Trump is spending the weekend in his New
Jersey Golf Club
Errol Barnett is traveling with the
president Errol good morning good
morning yes it's about to be a busy few
days President Trump told us that he
expects to interview two candidates
while he's at his golf course here in
New Jersey this weekend and the
president was sure to highlight that two
women are on his shortlist this will be
in addition to interviews that will take
place on Monday when the president
returns to Washington President Trump
arrived in New Jersey expecting to
interview potential replacements for
retiring Supreme Court Justice Anthony
Kennedy
CBS News has learned there are two
leading contenders Brett Kavanaugh a 53
year old Circuit Judge in Washington and
46 year old Amy Coney Barrett who the
president recently appointed to the
Seventh Circuit in Chicago also up for
consideration is a multiple of 49 year
old circuit court judge in Cincinnati
who would be the first Indian American
to serve on the Supreme Court the
president has been expressing excitement
about nominating a second Supreme Court
justice now I've done a good job with
judges judge hostage Supreme Court
justice Gorsuch earlier in the week mr.
Trump highlighted his vision to reshape
the High Court for decades we have to
pick one that's gonna be there for 40
years 45 years and reminded supporters
his judicial nominees only survived if
Republicans keep control of the Senate
we will vote to confirm Justice
Kennedy's successor this fall Republican
Senate Leader Mitch McConnell wants to
make use of his party's razor thin
majority now because Democrats might win
back control of the upper chamber after
the midterm elections cording key votes
the president hosted six senators at the
White House Thursday including three
vulnerable Democrats this week
Democratic efforts to push off
confirmation votes until next year were
quickly rebuffed Senator McConnell
famously held up President Obama's
Supreme Court pick Merrick garland for
ten months back in 2016
citing the upcoming election Democrats
want him to do the same now too close to
elections let's let the people decide
but McConnell rejected the comparison
nobody on either side has ever suggested
before yesterday that the Senate should
only process Supreme Court nominations
in odd-numbered years adding to the
tension both sides know this pick could
change the balance of the court for a
generation what's at stake is whether or
not
we'll continue to recognize or not a
woman's right to choose
now Republicans can approve this nominee
with a simple majority vote but that's
only if pro abortion rights Republicans
vote yes Lisa Murkowski of Alaska and
Susan Collins of Maine both of whom were
at the White House meeting earlier this
week said they want a nominee who views
Roe versus Wade as settled law President
Trump though told us aboard Air Force
One that he feels it's inappropriate to
discuss views of Roe versus Wade during
the interview process Dana
Errol Barnett with the president thank
you Errol